What have you been up to these days?
I've been busy.
I've been really busy reading
a lot of Andy's tweets.
I'm really excited.
Andy's been tweeting a lot
about some important stuff.
Yesterday, he had a great one.
This is a real one, right?
This is a real tweet.
He had a great tweet yesterday.
I don't know if we have--
I think we have it.
Yeah, we have it.
Put it up.
Here we go.
Just ran over a fallen
orange in the alley.
Car windows open, so received aroma bonus.
Very satisfying. 10 out of 10.
(audience cheering and applauding)
I mean.
It's called fan outreach,
you might wanna try it.
It's called hubris, Andy.
(Conan and audience laughing)
Oh, I just chipped my toenail,
I better alert the whole world!
I just tried something,
it's called ketchup!
What are you talking about?
I like to share!
(Will groans)
Yeah, it's pretty infuriating
when he does, isn't it?
It is infuriating.
You've turned me against him!
(all laughing)